a Sci-Fi Legend is back in avatar The
Way of water somehow so how does that
work spoilers ahead Avatar fans will of
course recall that Sigourney Weaver's
character in The groundbreaking 2009
film Dr Grace Augustine died near the
end of the movie after being fatally
wounded during an escape so when it was
announced that the alien star would be
reuniting with James Cameron and Company
for the sequel shortly after the first
film's release it obviously left fans
scratching their heads what's wrong with
this picture sequel Avatar the way of
water not only revisits Jake Sully and
natiri but also introduces us to their
Navi children including loac natayam and
Tuck possibly more significant than any
of their biological Offspring however is
their adopted Navi daughter Kiri played
by Sigourney Weaver the biological
daughter of Dr Augustine Kiri is taken
in by Sully and his family and comes
along with them as they must leave their
Forest Home and live amongst the
metcaina ocean Clan Kiri is more than an
excuse to bring Weaver back into the
franchise however as the character's
significance to the way of water could
very well signify big things to come
down the line Kiri is introduced early
on in avatar The Way of water as Dr
Augustine's daughter although rather
than being born human she is a full-on
navi from the start as director James
Cameron explained to Entertainment
Weekly it's just that she's born of
Grace's Avatar it's a natural birth but
the Avatar is brain dead but she's not
she's normal this also plays into kiri's
character as she longs to connect with
her deceased mother while remaining
self-conscious about living up to her
Navi family she has a special connection
to the environment around her which
takes on a new life when she and Sully's
family are forced out of their home by a
vengeful Colonel quarrich and make base
with the metcaina people as Kiri
explores the Lush oceans and comes face
to face with the water's colorful
inhabitants she also finds new ways to
connect and utilizes her abilities in
unique ways she not only connects with
the underwater Tree of Souls and claims
to hear the heartbeat of the deity AWA
but is also able to communicate with the
sea creatures which comes in Andy during
the film's climax curie's abilities make
her stand out enough from her motion
captured co-stars but it is her
viewpoints on life that could spell a
bigger picture for the upcoming Avatar
sequels by the end of the way of water
we know that the war between the navi
and humanity is far from over but just
as Colonel quartich's son spider who
shares a close bond with Kiri has love
for both the human and Navi World kiri's
non-violent ways and connection with the
world around her could turn the tide by
showcasing a different way around these
seemingly never-ending conflict as the
Avatar franchise is very much about
Humanity's exploitation of Natural
Resources Kiri could be the key to
unlocking how to better utilize those
elements for good on top of that we
still don't know who kiri's father is or
even if she has one we know she has her
limits as is evident when she suffers a
seizure while trying to connect to the
underwater Tree of Souls so learning
more about her Origins might be able to
help figure out why Kiri is one of the
many mysteries in the way of water but
she's one that Sigourney Weaver is
prepared to explore as she says in a
recent interview view with d23 I was
thrilled that Jim wouldn't trust me with
such a character I felt an immediate
connection to her I knew it would be
probably the biggest challenge I've ever
taken on when Jim Cameron calls you and
says I have three more parts of this
adventure what are you going to say no I
think he had me at hello
[Music]